[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight for a few overheated hours on
Saturday a group of boys from a Catholic
High School in Kentucky became the most
hated figures in America television
anchors denounced them as bigots
journalists with Harvard degrees called
them privileged Republican commentators
scolded them as bad Christians famous
actors suggested they should be hunted
down and punched in the face some on
social media called for them to be
killed the boys stood accused of mocking
an elderly Vietnam veteran an American
Indian man and doing it in the shadow of
the Lincoln Memorial
now the story had no inherent new
significance it didn't mobilize troops
or move markets or reopen the government
but as a symbolic event it's hard to
remember a moment more galvanizing in
Washington as they read their Twitter
feeds the leaders of this country were
in rare and solemn agreement these
teenage monsters these remorseless thugs
from our backward provinces are living
examples of all that is rotten in
immoral about America that was a
consensus on Saturday pretty much
everybody agreed with it and then
suddenly the Covington Catholic story
exploded popped like an overfilled
balloon animal new footage of the event
emerged and it turns out the boys never
attacked anyone in fact they stood in
place as others approached and harassed
them people did indeed scream racial
epithets at the Lincoln Memorial over
the weekend but it wasn't Catholic kids
from Kentucky watch a bunch of child
molesters call these dusty cracks with
that racist garbage oh look at these
dirt tracks that's right
a bunch of babies now whatever it is you
just saw in that tape it does not
confirm what they were telling you on
Saturday on Twitter just the opposite
the official story was a lie
and who knows what would have happened
to the boys from Cummings and Catholic
if the tape you just saw had never been
posted to the Internet they'd probably
be living under assumed names by now
instead the facts exonerated them and
implicated their accusers from brunch
tables across Washington reporters
rushed to delete their outraged tweets
some of them even apologized for passing
rash judgment and good for them but
amazingly many others pretended that
nothing had happened
they didn't acknowledge the new tape
they kept up their original attacks
being woke means never having to say
you're sorry
CNN political analyst Christian powers
now says the boys are guilty of quote
disrespecting an indigenous elder that
elder would be Nathan Phillips the man
with the now-famous drum there is
growing evidence tonight that Phillips
concocted key elements of his story as
well as parts of his own biography and
that he's done it before the press isn't
rushing to find out Kirsten powers
doesn't seem to care one way or the
other nor did she explain how precisely
the boys disrespected Phillips identity
politics doesn't concern itself with
details like these it's not about
individuals or what actually happened to
specific people on a given day identity
politics is a set of moral judgments
about groups some groups are always
right no matter what the tape shows
Laura Wagner didn't even bother to look
at the tape Wagner is a reporter at
Deadspin that used to be a sports site
before the Revolution began in an
article last night Wagner described the
boys behavior at the Lincoln Memorial as
quote a racially charged frenzy of
barely contained violence that was
committed by a quote frothing mass of
Magha youth frenzied and yelling and out
of control she went on like this
paragraph after paragraph and of course
anyone who disagree with that assessment
is a racist keep in mind as you read
that that there is literally nothing
in the record the documentary record on
tape or the testimony of anyone to
support any of Wagner's claims every
word is just made up out of nothing
imagine if someone was writing things
like that about your son at Covington
Catholic classes were cancelled today
thanks to people like Laura Wagner there
were too many threats here are two
seniors from the school several media
platforms blatantly lied about the
events regarding the controversy in DC
in an aspect of us as a community and
individuals greatly there have been many
threats against their lives against our
parents some of these threats include
that we should all be locked in the
school and should be burned to the
ground the school being bombed school
shooting threats I myself wasn't even
present but I'm very vocal about
defending my school in my peers and I
have been dashed on three separate
occasions there are real consequences
for these actions and it all spews from
a 30-second clip taken out of a two-hour
video out of context and people jumping
to conclusions before the Vig before the
full story is released and nobody did
their research and it's now showing
you'd think somebody at some point in
mediaand would wonder how all of this
miss reporting is affecting the kids who
were falsely accused but know there is
no sympathy for Covington Catholic in
America's newsrooms in the mind of your
average reporter in Washington these
kids are from a different country less
than that actually they're from a
hostile country a place we must subdue
for our own safety that's the attitude
and it may account for the left embrace
of violent rhetoric in the age of Trump
back more than a year ago when CNN
anchors publicly defended in Tifa it
seemed at the time like they might have
misspoken maybe they didn't know what
and Tifa was now it's clear they do
exactly what and Tifa was a ruling class
has told us that they're fine with
punching nazis now they've declared
they're okay with punching children how
long before they're okay with punching
you